[Music]
okay everyone so I'm really really
excited today because if you've seen my
review on the movie relic you know I
absolutely love this film and I just
wanted to talk to the director of it so
badly because powerful films like this
it's hard to put into words for me to
even say how it affected me so much but
it did so I thought maybe if I talked to
the director she'd have a better job
explaining how she put in these
wizarding tricks and these effects and
what blows my mind about it is that this
is a director this is her featured a
beaut she also co-wrote it I am joined
by Natalie Erica James how are you today
Natalie really well thanks for having me
and what an intro amazing thank you know
I'm you deserve it for making such a
credible film I think there was so many
things about it that really stood out to
me the first thing I wanted to say was
when I was watching it what would spoke
to me audio-wise was that you're barely
using a score here and there's so much
silence to it that's so effective and
makes it more creepy Gary so because
it's your first film I wonder like where
was this a super conscious choice on
your part to let like sound kind of
carried away with like the creaking
noises cuz it's a confident move it
obviously works but like what were your
thought process on like how you handle
the score and stuff yeah no we
definitely wanted to try and stay away
from a more traditional orchestral score
that was really conscious I'm always a
big fan of kind of using diegetic sound
or sounds that already exist in the
world of the film and heightened it -
ting them in some way and making them
unsettling through using that sound and
so with our sound designer and composer
they you know one was in Sydney one was
in LA but they actually worked really
closely together because they each
recorded stands and spent some time and
laughing a bit of a library that they
shared so the end result was when we
brought up
together it kind of felt very cohesive
because they were using essentially the
same you know oral language and yeah it
was just a matter of kind of yeah cut
combining to in the sound mix so yeah I
kind of I guess we were really looking
for an organic kind of sound you know
it's tricky to find the sound of growing
mold but yeah we really wanted to have
to have the presence you know to give a
sense of that through the sound
yeah and I think it matches so well to
with like there's this just like quiet
eeriness to it that also works visually
with the lights flickering that you have
in the beginning and throughout setting
this kind of mood in the house and I I'm
curious too that this is a question a
lot of fans had about this film but so
with sound in the knocking earlier in
the film they noticed there's knocking
over the mantel place was that the
grandma in the house at that time yeah
that's right why okay yes so the idea
being that she's you know instead of you
expect that she's kind of trapped or you
know missing out in the woods somewhere
but she's actually in fact trapped
inside a house that is green yes sir
you know a lot of the time with we try
to draw as much on reality and the
reality of the experience without
primers and there's this common you know
phenomenon that occurs where a lot to be
with the Alzheimer is there something to
do with on music kind of being like a
conduit of memories and so often if you
play music for them they'll still
remember you know the song itself so we
were kind of really fascinated by that
idea and that's why in some ways when
you know unreleased characters playing
that song data it almost brings her out
of the labyrinth itself you could read
it like that okay so that's that's
really interesting because even when you
bring up just the Alzheimer's part and
dementia here it's a deeply personal
film you've come out and said I have to
ask I mean that's also
why it spoke to me a lot and you make it
so you do it in such a way that's not on
the nose but it's it's getting you
almost subconsciously if that makes
sense is an audience member yeah I want
to ask you just four people aspiring to
write when you're writing a script like
that and you're taking you know deeply
personal maybe events it's routing from
how are you translating that into like a
script when you set out like is it very
similar as are you kind of just using a
little base of it I think it just comes
down to the emotional truth of the
experience so boy you're really
transferring like the closest thing I
would say that I've had happen here
because this film is so heightened is
you know when your loved one kind of is
talking to people who aren't there or is
convinced that there's someone you know
like my grandmother was convinced there
was someone a man and her closet and
that wasn't the case but you still get
very freaked out by that notion so I
guess it's that feeling that you
translate into the script and then you
take it to it supernatural extreme
because of course within a horror
framework yeah and I feel like you play
it so well back and forth between that
supernatural extreme but like very human
moments like for example when you have
Emily mourn Amir's character and Kay
when she actually cries in the car so
this was really powerful after she
visits the home and I think so many
people can relate to that feeling she
has of like oh you want to do what's
right for your parents but you also have
them in your head saying like you're you
know doing the wrong thing or you're
betraying them by doing that and yeah I
have you experienced that in your life
like if you felt that kind of like pull
back and forth that that might come with
I think well my parents are a little bit
younger and I think it's um it was more
based on my observations of you know my
parents relationships with their parents
and there can be a real resistance to
being looked after because you know
there's a real shift in dynamics as well
and I think it's kind of magnified when
you don't necessarily get on in the
first place
and that is just exacerbated when you
have this very you know very real
problem of someone's physical or mental
decline and it's just a very fraught
time so I think I've I was drawing on
yeah certain observations not to say
that you know my parents relationship
with their parents are exactly the same
as that but yeah I think you just draw
inspiration from the very complicated
emotions that surround those sorts of
decisions and there's never a right
decision you know a sentence a film
isn't saying that nursing homes are bad
in any way there's just a certain
heartbreak associated to you know when
people need to need to answer them and
can't be independent and are you know
resistant to losing their independence
yeah yeah and I'm with that too you're
talking about there's like a you know
there's no answer given there it's a
complicated thing and you have such
complicated characters in a sense and I
wonder with your three leads here when
you were casting them were you also
conscious of maybe how they looked like
to me I kind of felt like Sam casting
Bella Heathcote was like I don't know
why me reminded me like Alice from Alice
in Wonderland where she's the one who
kind of goes down the rabbit hole and is
a little more innocent I don't know if
you thought I I thought it worked that
way like because to me that's also I
don't know I'm just like was there ideas
you had casting wise that you needed for
these main three parts yes you know that
Alice in Wonderland thing is interesting
it had never occurred to me but that's I
love hearing people's interpretations
with material so it gives me such joy so
you know I guess Edna was was really
important because she has to play so
many you know the actor ice it's like
something facets of that character and
it was really key that the audience was
really sympathetic to her as well even
though she obviously you know lashes out
and there's a question about whether
there's something sinister going on so
yeah I was really looking for someone
who could who could play both sides
there are the many sides to her and
robin egg and you know
it's such a you know she's a force like
she is a brilliant actor in that she can
convey vulnerability so well but then
also she can dredge up anger very
quickly as well and sir she had that
kind of double edged vulnerability and
brutality to her yes that's one example
was very important casting joke
ya know and I think that totally came
off that way and I thought what was
interesting too is that the decision
writing wise that you didn't make it
like oh let's do a bunch of flashbacks
into Sam Hayes backstory and I think
that worked really well but like that's
another thing to talk about like with
the confidence you had here like can you
kind of give your kind of philosophy on
that because a lot of people think too
many movies do that and that you
sometimes need it and some right I don't
like what what made you not want to do
it here if that makes sense yeah I mean
I guess sometimes I mean flashbacks
aren't perfectly fine but sometimes they
can feel like you're holding the
audience's hand too much mm-hmm and I
think you know maybe filmmakers need to
give audiences a bit more credit I mean
you want you want what you're saying
with the film to come across in a way
you don't want to alienate people but I
think not I kind of embrace ambiguity a
little bit and I don't think everything
needs to be spelled out so really on
screen say I'd say that's kind of my
general approach so I also really want
to ask you to because you're working
with you know amazing actresses here and
I thought the most brilliant acting by
Emily Mortimer in this film was actually
in one of the most brilliant ideas
thought in the film was with the post-it
notes that appear that you know go Sam
what's really happening with the grandma
and she's like writing a note to remind
herself that of her name and then to
then have it come to that you are loved
moment that Kay sees can you kind of
just describe on set what that was like
and directing Emily in that moment and
how you kind of guys get on the same
page of such a complicated scene where
Sam's leaving out the door the moms on
the Graham
on the floor and Ches kind of a big
moment like what was like the process
like for you there and Emily yeah I mean
I think what was really brilliant with
all three of the actors but also you
know with Emily in particular was that
we never really approached it like a
horror film you know there's obviously a
lot of horrific things going on and
really heightened things going on but I
think you just have to focus on the
what's the underlying kind of emotion or
you know so yeah I I think you almost
have to think of the the real-world
context in the real world's emotion that
is tied to that situation so even though
it is heightened with them you know and
uh kind of falling apart quite literally
on the floor it's more relying that to
kind of your your real lived experience
I think in defining the parallel yeah
that's amazing and honestly like it's
such a great moment because it gives you
like this emotional payoff that leads to
I think the best part of the movie which
is the final scene and I think okay I
think this final scene I'm not just
saying this like will go down and like
cinema history I was like iconic and
that's why it's crazy it's your first
movie that like no I know and I know I'm
sound like I'm blowing a bunch of smoke
up your butt but like hear me out like
that I was watching I least said if
Roger Ebert was still alive he would say
that that that scene was that way like
there's something special about it and I
I wonder seeing Kaye put her grandma on
the bed pulling the skin off it's creepy
it's eerie it's powerful it's sad it
makes you feel so much and it also
really hits that hard because it's like
a real-life horror but it's also mixed
in with like well har but I wonder I
mean also - I love that Sam comes in the
room they're lined up the three
generations a woman and then she sees
Kay's skin starting to peel - it's like
this thing we all have to face you know
that we're decaying and I want to know
because you again with writers you hear
all these different philosophies about
writing but like did this end come to
you Midway writing the script or was
this like from the beginning you knew
this was the end point
she talked to me about that um from the
first draft that always ended with his
family members in on a bit like lying
down together it went through a few
iterations and in originally the the
Menace or you know the other we call her
who and eventually becomes she
originally in the original script was
actually someone separate so it was
almost like a doppelganger and then we
decided that it made more sense for her
to be yeah because it is essentially the
same person it's just that they're
becoming someone else or losing parts of
themselves and changing on the inside so
yeah we kind of combine those two things
so it's a it was a little bit different
but it always ended with the same
sentiment so was it that scene like was
that just a vision in your head like how
do you like my because it really is like
how do you even like such a it's so
different that scene but like did you
just like one night you were sleeping
you're like oh my god like I got to get
this on film like how did that even get
there if I look back I found like a
recurring nightmare educated about my
mom dying
you know going out into this field of
red flowers and finding her coffin and
then I open the coffin and she see like
skeleton so you know that may be that
you only subconscious thing is that you
know just have an impact on you in some
way that you don't really recognize time
I think also it was really important in
terms of like the actual visual of the
other that had a really human fragile
vulnerable quality which again is just
drawn from the real-life terrorism you
know what people actually look like when
they are wasting away at the end of
their life so they can look you know
they're completely human in that moment
but they can look really an inhuman as
well because they're so different to how
you normally see them you know it's
helping individuals oh yeah there's I
guess they're just trying to capture the
horror of that know that
it's beautifully said and I've had such
a great time talking to you Natalie
you're a true genius
I think excitement around you being in
the game now and I I also want to say
that like I feel like hard directors are
like the rock star directors right now
and I like people love that like that
there's just awesome hard coming out
right now and I want to kind of compare
it to because Relic we've already seen
now with all the reviews it's getting
such high praise and it reminds me of
kind of re asters journey where he had
like hereditary come out and was like
this sleeper hit or people like who is
this director it's the same thing that's
happening with you and I'm wondering
like you know people are gonna say okay
like what's gonna be your next film can
she live up today feel that pressure or
you kind of just taken a day at a time
completely I think you of course feel
the pressure you know in some ways you
just have to focus on the work and not
let it get to you but yeah I I think I I
you know you I think it's really
important to like celebrate your wounds
as well to enjoy it and not let the
pressure of what's next kind of take
that away so yeah I appreciate you
saying that that's really lovely no yeah
and and before we go to I just wanted to
ask is there anything else you wanted to
promote or any future projects that we
should look forward to or any you want
to plug in general I'm writing a few
things at the moment but I'm the one
that kind of furthest along is there so
course set in Japan and it's very much
kind of in the vein of the Wickerman or
Rosemary's Baby and I guess it's you
know relic was about death and mortality
this is the opposite it's about birth
and creation and motherhood and
sacrifice that's that's so exciting
that's going to be a feature that'll be
a feature oh that's that is awesome to
hear I cannot wait everyone please I
don't know what you're doing you haven't
watch this movie ready but check out
relic now it's streaming video on demand
and drive-in theaters Natalie thank you
so much for joining me and I hope to
talk to you again someday in the future
thanks so much